because ladies and gentlemen straight
from his triumphant run at goddamn
Gotham City's premier comedy club I'd
laugh if I were you give it up for the
comedy stylings of Bane okay folks so
the main comedy club Bane is Frank
predicated on I've not seen the jokes
before so so this is Bane as real as
reimagined as a nightclub comic and
there's a set here so the last one has a
big round off back handspring multi tag
what the last one yeah so but so I get
to the second card it's big it's a bar
closer you'll feel that you'll feel that
it'll go like this it'll go like the
jokes are like okay then they go kind of
down then they go down then they come
back to okay and then at the end they go
pretty good at the end of it I'm like
crashing this plane
I've put together delectable a selection
of humorous oddities to speak about with
you at this comedy club prepare to laugh
ScienceDaily
Andy reports three habitable planets
found there what they call an ultra-cool
dwarf star ultra-cool dwarf star are
they watching the skies or Peter
Dinklage on Game of Thrones
I like to include a loose on a
pop-culture humor good for the soul
a study Johns Hopkins reveals that
one-third of deaths in the u.s. are due
to medical errors forget an apple a day
I'm keeping the doctor a will but the
restraining order I also have a
continuity related alternate line if
you'd like to hear that this is only for
the comic book people there's three of
them study at Johns Hopkins the world at
one-third of deaths in the u.s. are due
to middle class here's the ultimate joke
at the gangly what is Raja Ghul
practicing medicine research has
discovered old fossils of the sinkhole
Florida at Tallahassee but sure the US
was settled more than 14,500 years ago
they tried to study some fossils in
Pokhara Tom but the fossils kept yelling
get off my lawn
[Applause]
[Applause]
that would really played gotta wait to
bring that to the Conan show
I'm on a roll so in other fossil news
the fossilized relative of modern day
daddy longlegs was found to Burma Andrew
not only is it perfectly preserved in
amber as we saw Jurassic Park franchise
yeah a lot of hand-holding this audience
these little hand-holding not only was
it perfectly preserved in a bird also
has an erection that scientists estimate
[Music]
[Applause]
not only perfectly preserved in amber it
also has an erection band that
scientists estimate to be dyed did not
billion years old
[Applause]
it's just so perfectly good Tonight Show
so Leno could have done these here comes
the punchline you ready - ready you're
ready to rock come to the rock girl
world with this bunch I've listened if
you have an erection lasting boy I think
they connected the dots on that land if
you have an erection lasting more than
98 million years
[Applause]
you could just jump to the tag you don't
have to do that setup ergo this one well
you can do the tag there if you want the
second one yeah these jokes on the
Internet
sadly we're still speaking of the
fossilized daddy longlegs with the giant
erection sadly his little hands were
frozen just out of reach your disturb
has been trying to masturbate for die to
die ability bliss
he's like the scratch of masturbation I
like the ice age films more science news
and day sciences have discovered that
just by analyzing the air exhaled by
audiences they could determine what kind
of movie their watch yeah yes motion
pictures what kind of air means it's a
suspense movie and another kind of a
means of course with its comedy just by
just by analyzing the air that audiences
are breathing science go figure
but if there's no air it must be the
movie funny monster not a lot of people
went Jodie Foster fans in the audience I
see here's the alternate baby the air is
filled with farts it's as a Wayans
brothers movie
I told you now we're in that like dip
area of the jokes down in there
the first commercial flight of bugs new
spaceship the CST 110 star liners moved
to January of 2018 after this I was if
you thought the delays on US Airways
were long your jokes are fair like a
family research experts are looking into
the reasons why buddy brothers disliked
the daughter's choice for a husband they
called this the Juliet effect because
Lady Capulet did not like Romeo
now if the father wants to marry the
daughter they call this the Woody Allen
effect its ethical he's a can you know
his true is at International Film
Festival he should be expecting these
types of jabs and being that I have a
supervillain a job was the easiest to
get for me the man is small he's 80 I
could crush his windpipe but he lives
now scientists at UC
scientists at UC San Diego Andy San
Diego means a whale's vagina did you see
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
very funny scientist at UC San Diego
discovered a new species a pink
flatworms named the churro flat world a
flat yes because they revived the team
of churros the food that you could just
be world for $40
here comes the punchline here's my
question how bad are the jack
how bad are the churros at UC San Diego
keep your churro it looks like a big
[ __ ] pig flat worm it's a little
college humor plays on the road a steady
show the smartphones are giving a large
portion of the population symptoms of
ADHD this is true yes
all of the all the setups are true what
do you know about this in the real world
is that true it gives people attention
it's just it because your behaviors are
a B or C people will sit down at a
dinner and only talk for a couple
minutes before taking their phones out
and doing stuff that's true we're all
reconditioned so they're thinking sort
of attention fans are shortening because
that's a learned behavior not an
ingrained or innate behavior study shows
the smart folks are giving a large
portion of the population symptoms of
ADHD and again for those of you on your
smartphone the study shows that
smartphones are giving a large portion
of the population symptoms of ADHD okay
I'm going to rock through with my closer
try got material for my Netflix specials
the bane of comedy
I hope it is watched as the iliza
shlesinger special my [ __ ] was funny
there we go
the 70 year old woman in India just gave
birth to her first child Wow 70 years
old and she gave birth to her first
child that's amazing that's very old for
a person to give birth to a child
especially the first one I Magic Man in
you thanks for the assist
let's go so rudely interrupted
[Music]
seven-year old woman and indeed just
gave birth to her first child boy you
forget the world robber just once or you
can watch her a whole story on MTV's you
could watch a holster on MTV it was 69
and pregnant it's actually easier for
her to raise the kid because she
produces powdered breast milk
conversely the baby's teeth are coming
out just as her teeth are coming out
she's going straight for nursing at the
breast right to the nursing home but the
good news is that she's had lots of
practice changing diapers I deserve the
respect standing in front of people
saying things for abuse but - takes
courage Catholic takes no courage
whatsoever is the doorway to the demise
young demise at the hands of a super
villain I'll make you suck my dick son
[Applause]
and then wended math with about lies and
ashes then you have my permission to cry
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Nance meet Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder